FEMALE SPEAKER: Please join
me in welcoming Jason Ng.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON Q. NG: Great.
No, thank you so much for having
me, Ann-- especially to Ann,
and everybody here at Google.
And also, to the
Google Policy Team,
I want to especially
thank Paul Nicholas
for helping arrange this talk.
So thanks you all
for coming out.
Hopefully, this will be a little
light-hearted fun opportunity
for you to learn a little bit
about some of the issues that
are taking place within
the Chinese online sphere,
and also about how they affect
our own issues here in the US
and abroad.
So yeah, so a lot
of people always
ask me how I started with this.
I was actually a book
editor for a long time,
and I was an English major.
And folks wonder
how I got interested
in online issues and
internet censorship.
And I often point them to
this one particular chart,
which may look
familiar to some of you
folks who work on Google Trends.
This is an image of
search volume coming out
of a particular
province in China called
Xinjiang in the Northwest
from the dates ranging
from 2009 to 2010.
And even if you don't
work on Google Trends,
you might be able to tell that
something odd is taking place
here.
Clearly, something
that has dropped off,
and something didn't happen.
And what didn't happen was there
was no internet in Xinjiang
for roughly 10 months from
July 29, 2009, to May 2010.
And if you don't
trust Google's data,
you could also perform the same
sort of thing on Baidu index,
and you'll get the
same sort of thing.
For 10 months, there
was no internet
essentially in an entire
province in China.
And when we're talking
about provinces,
we're talking about
regions that are roughly
the size of whole
countries in other places.
So it was from here that
I got really interested
in the ability of
governments and authorities
to really control the online
sphere, which a lot of folks
thought was completely
uncontrollable.
There's the famous quote
of Bill Clinton saying
controlling the internet is
like nailing jello to the wall.
And obviously, China
has done something
to figure out a way to
strap jello to the wall,
and that way is using various
forms of online censorship.
However, the only thing
is you probably won't ever
find China perform
this sort of thing
again for multiple reasons.
But one-- it would
scare the begeezus out
of economic investors
and other businesses.
People would flee if
China ever turned off
the internet in, say,
Beijing if they were faced
with some sort of riots
or some sort of unrest.
So that's one reason.
But two, also because there's
whole other sorts of tactics
that they can use now.
They're much more nuanced
and sophisticated than simply
just turning off the internet
if there's a riot in a province.
And some of those obviously
are the famed IP blocking
and the blacklisting of
sites in China, which
many of you I'm
sure are aware of.
So YouTube, Facebook, Twitter
are all essentially blocked
from folks within
mainland China.
They're blocked from
mainland Chinese folks
from accessing them through
the so-called Great Firewall.
And then we have other
forms of blocking,
like the so-called
packet filtering.
If you try and
reach websites that
have certain sensitive
keywords on them,
you may not be able to them.
But what I'm particularly
interested in
are the sort of
filtering and disruptions
that take place
on the site level.
These are issues that
are really complicated,
and have to deal with a
lot with self-censorship
by private companies
within China
who have to deal with
government oversight,
and trying to figure
out what do we allow,
and what do we not allow.
And in particular, I'm
focusing on search blocks
which is my area of expertise.
And I look at search blocks
on one particular social media
website, Sina Weibo, and
how they're implemented,
and what is actually blocked.
So if we move on-- but
first, what is Sina Weibo?
Some of you may
have heard about it,
and been familiar with perhaps
its reach and its power
now within China.
And some folks refer to it
as a sort of Twitter copycat,
but it's more than
just a Twitter copycat.
Sure, you all have on Weibo
your own 140-character posts
that you can put up
on your own page.
But it also has this
ability to-- there's polls
on Sina Weibo.
There threaded comments, so you
can have conversations on Weibo
very easily.
There's ways of dating
portal type activity.
It's more akin to Facebook
than actually just a Twitter
microblog site.
So what sort of content
do you find on Sina Weibo?
Stuff like this.
People posting this
sort of content
that you would find in Western
social media-- frivolous,
fun pictures of stuffed
animals and people's pets.
So that's one kind of content
you find on Sina Weibo.
However, you also can find
stuff like this-- slightly more
provocative images
that were circulated.
This one was from 2012.
There was a chemical
factory protest in Sichuan,
and there was this
iconic photo that
was circulated across Weibo
of a young lady protesting
against this building of
a PX chemical factory.
And this image was circulated,
eventually before it
was actually
censored and blocked
from being shared on Weibo.
So again, like you would
find in Western media,
Weibo is this powerful tool
for not just playful humor,
but also for more
provactive organizing
like you would
find in this image.
So does the government
recognize the power of Weibo?
Yes, they do.
They realize that Weibo cannot
only be this force for creating
unrest and disturbances,
and perhaps disrupting
what's taking place
with the status quo,
but also can be this really
fascinating way to have
oversight over local officials.
It's an opportunity to
have really great feedback
toward internet users.
And so there's this quote from
this Party Journal in 2012,
the "Study Times,"
where they state,
Sina Weibo-- "It's like
a double-edged sword;
it not only allows us
to respond to crises
will provide a tool that is more
scientific and more expedient,
also has limitations
or negative effects
that are very prominent."
So the government
is aware that they
need to control Weibo if
they want to make sure
that the things stay the
same as they are now.
So ways that the government
goes about it-- actually,
they've been ramping
up on their side.
And in response,
internet users have
been ramping up on
their side, too.
So when the government
and authorities
implement all sorts
of new technology
to monitor and surveil
citizens, and to censor content,
internet users respond.
So one of the ways that
I like to talk about
is how government
and the authorities
figured out a way to really
quickly highlight and figure
out-- find posts-- that contain
sensitive content by work
searching for keywords.
In response, internet
users realized
that governments and
authorities were doing this,
and they decided to embed
their text within images.
So sort of a steganography
sort of technique.
However, the government
then responded in kind
by finding sensitive
content, sensitive images,
and doing sorts
of image searches,
and wiping them out right away.
So it's a cat and mouse game
that goes back and forth,
and it continues to this day.
So back to Weibo.
Some of the more specific ways
that the government actually
does filter content on Weibo.
Posting certain keywords, either
by themselves or in combination
with other keywords, will give
you this really vague message
that says, sorry, this content--
and if you're interested,
that keyword says
Wen Jiabao, who's
the former Prime
Minister in China.
And the message that you
get is, sorry, this content
violates Sina's rules,
blah, blah, blah.
If you need assistance, please
contact customer service.
I wish you luck if you feel
like contacting them, and seeing
what you get back.
So another way that they do
it, simply by deleting content.
Content sometimes vanishes
from Weibo without a trace,
except there been websites like
Free Weibo-- freeweibo.com--
that actually suck up
all the tweets that get
posted on Weibo before
they get deleted.
And then when they
do get deleted,
they actually
retain a copy of it,
and then share it with everyone.
So this is an image that
took place in [? Mingboa ?]--
or where this is an image
of an event that took place
in [? Mingboa ?] last week,
or two weeks ago, actually.
We're not quite sure what's
happening in the photo,
but we do know that
apparently policemen
are dragging away a man.
And the image was
censored on Weibo.
Actually, someone
posted it, and then
within a short amount of time,
it was no longer on Weibo.
And actually, if you're trying
to access it through the API,
it'll give you a
message that says,
sorry, this content doesn't
exist, or permission denied.
So that's another
technique that Weibo
is very famed for using
to get rid of content.
But my particular form
of-- again, like I said,
the information
control technique
that I'm most interested
in is the search blocks.
Search blocks are very flexible.
You can add words
to the list one day,
take them off the next day.
Content's still there.
However, what you're
doing is inhibiting people
from finding information.
So there's some sort
of protest going on,
someone wants to look
up information on it,
if the sort of keywords that
they're using to look for it
are on that blacklist, they'll
get this message that says,
due to relevant laws, we
can't show you results.
And for this one, this
keyword is "Wen Yunsong,"
who was actually the
son of Wen Jiabao.
And he's notable in China
for being a billionaire.
And you wonder, how did this
guy become a billionaire?
His father, perhaps?
So this sort of thing touches
on sensitive issues in China.
A lot of times, these words are
blocked on Weibo in addition
to being filtered in other ways.
So I'm not the only one
doing this sort of research.
A lot of other folks
I was inspired by,
and have continued my
line of work-- especially
folks at "China Digital Times,"
Gary King at Harvard, folks
at the University of Hong
Kong-- who made a great tool
called Weiboscope-- David
Bamman, Carnegie Mellon,
and his associates
at Carnegie Mellon,
and Jed Crandall and
his associates at UNM.
And GreatFire.org,
which like I said,
they do Free Weibo,
which is that tool
that I showed before about
tracking deleted posts.
And also, this tool
called GreatFire.org
where you can actually
see over time historically
the sort of key
words and information
that's blocked on Weibo.
So this one is showing
you across time
from March 2012 up to now
how Weibo treated searches
for Bo Xilai, who was
this corrupt politician--
or allegedly, corrupt
politician who
was recently convicted, and
sentenced to life in prison
for his various
nefarious activities.
And you'll see that
based on current events,
his name may or
may not be blocked.
So for instance, you'll see
at the beginning of April,
there was a shift.
That was when a lot of
the scandals and rumors
started to pop up.
In late September,
there's another shift.
That's when he was actually
kicked out of the party.
And then all of a sudden, people
were able to search for him.
And people claim that that's
perhaps due to the fact
that the government
wanted to continue
to allow citizens to
criticize him online.
So as you can see,
there's a correlation
between online events
and offline events, which
seems fairly intuitive, but
it's good to have the data there
to actually show you.
So continuing on.
So what did I do?
GreatFire, "China Digital
Times," they do fantastic work
in confirming, I think,
what is sensitive
and what isn't sensitive.
So for instance, Bo Xilai is
in the news about a corruption
scandal.
Let's check and see if
he's blocked on Weibo,
and to confirm whether
or not Weibo thinks
he's sensitive,
and worth blocking.
However, what about all the
words that we don't know
are sensitive?
Like for instance, "foot
fetish," or other things
like that?
I think that's
where I stepped in.
And what I did was I took
a giant list of words.
In this case, Wikipedia's
article titles
in the Chinese language
addition, which totaled up
to 700,000 keywords,
and I ran them
through Sina Weibo in
this very simple script
that tested or not whether
or not each word was blocked
or not.
And then I recorded
them into a database,
and basically did various
things to try and understand
why they were blocked,
including doing research
into the history, the language,
and other sorts of things.
So in the end, I came up
with 500 blocked keywords.
And in the book,
I have 150 of them
that I write up in
more detail, reasons
about why they are considered
sensitive in Chinese culture,
and to the Chinese government.
So without context,
some of the words
that I've organized thematically
throughout the book.
So words related to government,
CCP, politics, and nationalism.
So a lot of them
are fairly obvious.
Some of them less so unless
you know the context, which
hopefully I provide
in the book, and which
I'll do with some of
these words in more detail
later on in the presentation.
So some other words about
dissent, censorship,
and justice; sex,
drugs, immorality;
people, scandals,
disasters, and rumors.
As some you know--
may know-- there's
been a big anti-rumor
campaign going on
in China during the
past several months.
So rumors are clearly on the
mind of the censors these days.
Information and media; security,
violence, and other words
that deal with people
being suppressed.
And then there are words I
just don't have a clue why.
And I think these
really remind us
that there's a human
element involved here.
There are people
actually putting
these words on the list, and
they know what's going on,
so yeah.
All right, so we'll just go
through a few of the words,
and hopefully this will be
an opportunity for you guys
to give me some--
shout out if you
know why they might be blocked.
But here's one.
If you don't read Chinese,
hopefully the pronunciation
might help you out.
Any thoughts?
There you go.
So tank-- [SPEAKING_CHINESE]--
is actually a reference
to "tank man."
It was blocked for some
time in early 2012.
it's actually unblocked
now, so now you
can search for tanks to your
heart's delight on Weibo.
But you're not going to
see this image on Weibo,
or through any sort
of search engine
in China, either, because
obviously it refers back
to this precarious time
in Chinese history.
In 1989, the day
after the soldiers
came in and cleared
the Square, this man
stood there on June 5th, and
blocked a column of tanks
from entering and/or leaving
from Tianamen Square.
And that's what we have.
Here's another one.
Literally, it means
"hairy bacon."
You pronounce it
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
"Mao" means "hair,"
and [SPEAKING CHINESE]
is sort of like a preserved
meat, like a jerky or bacon.
And however, "mao" isn't
only just a word for "hair,"
it's also a surname--
a Chinese surname.
If some of you may know a
famous Mao in Chinese history.
And so, Mao Zedong.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
doesn't also just mean
preserved meat that
you eat, but also
a different kind of preserved
meat-- Mao's body, which
is laid in state
inside Tianamen Square.
So this is an example of a
coded keyword where are internet
users have decided that this
is some sort of coded insult
for Mao, but also an insult
for the current government.
So for instance, they'll say
things to the effect of, oh,
[SPEAKING CHINESE[
certainly wouldn't approve
of today's policies--
economic reform policies.
So it's a way to get around
the censors by using words
that the censors wouldn't
have known to block.
However, as I've shown, the
censors figured this one out.
They blocked it.
And the only reason I
was able to figure out
that internet users
were using this word
was because it was blocked.
In fact, when I was
researching the book,
and I actually figured out
this was a blocked word,
I asked multiple
native speakers then.
They had never
heard of the phrase.
And in fact, it's
so obscure, I only
find it in a couple
of places-- in fact,
in a recipe for how to
prepare [SPEAKING CHINESE].
Apparently, you
dip it in nitrate,
and eventually,
it's able to keep
in a glass case
for up to 40 years.
So I think this is an example of
the sort of so-called Streisand
effect-- the fact that
someone tried to prevent you
from blocking it gave
greater prominence to it.
Because otherwise,
who would have
known that [SPEAKING CHINESE]
was a sensitive term, when
in fact so few people
actually use this thing?
So again, internet users being
playful, and being caught up
with it.
Here's another one.
This one is actually not
created by internet users,
but by official media-- in this
case, official media in Hong
Kong.
If you guys aren't
familiar, China
has this sort of one
country, two systems
rule wherein Hong Kong has a
sort of more liberal policies
with regards to
freedom of information,
freedom of expression.
Their political system is
more free than it is in China.
And in this case--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON Q. NG: Yeah.
So "empty stool" refers
to the empty chair
that Liu Xiaobo
would have sat in,
but was vacated at the 2010
Nobel Peace Prize ceremony.
So "empty stool" was a
reference in Hong Kong media,
talking about the empty stool.
And so there you have it.
So media is also
closely watched,
not just internet users.
Here's one that internet users
were able to contribute to.
This one is [SPEAKING
CHINESE] which
literally means
"month month bird."
But as an example of the sort of
games that internet users like
to play, this actually--
if you put them together--
equals a single character,
[SPEAKING CHINESE],
in reference to
[SPEAKING CHINESE], who
was the former
Premiere of China.
And he was actually the one
in June 4-- back in 1989
who actually pushed
for the government
to enter into the Square, and
be more assertive about dealing
with the protesters.
So he's clearly a
controversial figure
in Chinese current
events and history.
And so, references to his
name are sensitive online.
So when internet
users recognized
that you couldn't perhaps use
his name, or using his name
itself-- the one
with the characters
all squished together--
using his name is sensitive,
and may cause your post
to be deleted right away.
They decided to split it
up, and as a sort of game
to try and get
around the censors.
Unfortunately, this
was also caught.
And so, [SPEAKING CHINESE],
"month month bird,"
the monthly bird is now
no longer acceptable
discourse on Weibo.
OK, here's one that's more
historical in nature-- wu wang.
So it literally means "never
forget," or "don't forget."
And in this case,
this one is actually
a reference to a four-character
idiomatic phrase in China,
[SPEAKING CHINESE],
which means, "don't
forget that we're in Zhu," the
city of Zhu, which relates back
to a historical moment
in China wherein
this general and his
troops were actually
surrounded in a small city.
And these forces
were all around them.
And basically, he said
this phrase to them,
"Don't forget we're in
the city of [? Zhu." ?]
And then they fought back, and
they retook the country back.
So any thoughts what
parallels that might have to?
Ah, Taiwan.
So basically, this
inscription is actually
in [SPEAKING CHINESE].
And it was put there
by Chiang Kai-shek
as a sort of our rallying cry
to tell Taiwanese citizens
that we'll come take
back the mainland.
So clearly that's sensitive,
Taiwanese-Chinese politics.
But also, this phrase is
also used in a different way,
a different thing that
we shouldn't forget--
don't forget 6 4, or June 4th.
So again, that
phrase can be used
for historical slash
political references, but also
more recent events.
Another more recent
event-- so keywords
can oftentimes be related
to very contemporary events.
In this case, the
term "rich woman"
refers to a specific rich woman.
Guo Meimei, from
in recent years,
she actually was a women
who posted on Weibo
that she was an employee
of the Red Cross in China.
And she then flaunted images of
herself in front of a Maserati,
in front of her Hermes handbags,
first class plane tickets.
And obviously,
Chinese netizens were
outraged that someone
associated with a charity
could be so rich, they wondered
how she got her wealth.
Eventually, did this human
flush search-- essentially
netizens banding together to
figure out who a person is.
And they figured
out who she was.
And she had to come
out and apologize.
The Red Cross in China had
to come out and disassociate
themselves from her, and
say that she actually
wasn't an employee.
And in the end,
actually, this event
had severe repercussions
on the Red Cross in China.
And their donations
fell by something up
to close to 50%
the following year.
So the power of
internet users in China.
Two more, and then
we'll get to the Q&A.
And so this one, "gaoyaoqi."
This one's just sort
of fun. "Gaoyao"
means like plaster medicine,
or it's like plastic,
and "qi" is "flag."
So that refers back to a sort
of like a medicinal patch
that Chinese users
like, Chinese folks
use for healing themselves.
But it's also a coded
insult for the Japanese flag
and Japanese people,
because it sort of
looks like the Japanese flag.
So that's another fun
one playing with images.
And then the last one we'll
do-- "satellite television."
Again, a lot of these
words are out there.
I'm just putting
out my best guess.
But in this case, the reason
why this might be blocked
may be due to the fact that back
in, I believe in 1990s, Rupert
Murdoch tried to enter China
by creating this satellite
television company, Sky.
And he actually stated
in an interview,
"Advances in the technology
of communications
have proved an unambiguous
threat to totalitarian
regimes," and basically
said that we're
coming for you, China.
We're going to bring
in satellite TV.
We're going to open
up your country.
And Chinese folks didn't
take too kindly to this.
The Chinese authorities actually
banned satellite television,
so satellite dishes are
technically illegal in China.
And then Rupert Murdoch actually
had to spend the next decade
trying to recover
from that faux pas,
and trying to suck up to
the Chinese government.
And if you wander
around China today,
even though satellite dishes
are technically illegal,
you'll find that
folks have decided
to flaunt for flout that ban.
So I think that's the keywords
that I'll just present today.
If you're interested
in more, of course,
you could read my book, or
my blog, Blocked on Weibo.
But I just wanted to
close today by talking
a little bit about what we
can take away from this.
Seeing how Chinese authorities
regulate the internet
and control their information
online I think is fascinating,
not just in a purely
China context,
but also looking at how
things are affecting
regions around the world--
not just authoritarian regimes
in Iran, Syria, and elsewhere,
but also here in the US,
in Europe.
You have all sorts of tension
between private companies,
between governments,
between internet users
about how much information is
allowed to be shared online,
and what sorts of information
shouldn't be shared,
and who gets to decide.
I think that's sort
of the conversation
that hopefully my book
will be able to spur.
Where do we actually
draw the line
between trying to protect
the security of everyone
versus trying to promote
and allow folks to have
the individual expression
that we so need in societies?
So hopefully the
book isn't something
that's purely out
there to attack China,
but instead it's an opportunity
to understand the motives why
authorities might decide
to censor certain content.
And by doing this,
we can hopefully
figure out ways to provide
incentives, and try
and understand how
to nudge authorities
to trying to dismantle some
of these obviously very
restrictive environments that
we have around the world today.
So thank you so
much for having me,
and I'd be happy to take any
questions that you all have.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON Q. NG: I'll stand here.
So if you guys
have any questions
about China, particular key
words, about my research,
or anything else.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what are the
ages of the people who
are saying these
kind of key words.
Are they younger?
Because it seems like
a lot of the key words
you mention have
historical reference,
so I'm wondering
how much of that
[INAUDIBLE] the younger
people are cognizant of.
JASON Q. NG: Yeah, I think
that's a very important point.
The very fact that you
have to use sometimes
these coded keywords to
get around the censors
means that by the very nature
of using these keywords,
you're sort of losing
out on communicating
in a more direct fashion
with the mass folks.
So using [SPEAKING CHINESE]
or using that idiomatic phrase
means that the censors
are being effective.
They're essentially cutting
off a chance for you
to connect with everyone.
However, that's the
push for internet users
to try and use phrases
that are coded in a way,
but also very
understandable to everybody.
So for that idiomatic phrase,
maybe not everyone knows it.
But other things,
like May 35th, which
is a coded keyword for June
4th, I think most folks in China
do recognize what that means.
And so it's trying to find
within that cat and mouse game,
trying to find this to walk the
line of being evasive, but not
so evasive that
you don't actually
connect with internet users.
So in terms of actual
age, Weibo is primarily,
like most social media,
a youth-driven media-- so
folks, college kids.
But it's also really
been this powerful tool
for not just youth
and their frivolous
posting pictures of what
they did last night,
but also for activists
and journalists.
So you'll find a lot of those
folks online on Weibo, as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] did
your book get [INAUDIBLE]?
And secondly, did hashtags
play any role in [INAUDIBLE].
JASON Q. NG: So this
was interesting.
I was actually in
Toronto, and someone we
came up and asked a
question, or basically said,
oh, I posted on Weibo that
I was attending your talk,
and I posted an
image of your book.
And within five minutes,
the post disappeared.
So I don't know if that's
indicative of what's happening,
but it's interesting.
Maybe I shouldn't say
this, but the blog--
which the book is based
on-- isn't blocked in China,
because I think it's
written in English,
and it doesn't really have
a big user base in China.
So it doesn't really matter to
Chinese authorities so much.
But that is interesting.
As four hashtags,
I think hashtags
aren't quite as a big deal
on social media in China,
because one, perhaps, because
of language-- not issue,
but language opportunity.
Chinese is so much more
compact than English,
and that each character actually
represents an entire word.
So 140 characters,
you actually say
a good amount in 140 characters.
So you don't really
need hashtags
as a way of this sort of
reductive meme sort of tool.
So you're actually able
to say what you want.
But in Chinese
social media, I think
images are super powerful.
Those get circulated so widely.
Even images of whole essays.
So you'll often find people
who post-- they'll actually
type out a 300, 400, 500
characteristic essay--
sometimes even longer, make
an image of it, and post that.
And that sort of thing gets
circulated very widely.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
anecdote is
an example of how this cat
and mouse game evolves,
and you actually have
different tactics being used.
To what extent does your
research or continued research
on this indicate that there's
a different way that people
are trying to post
censored information,
and that censors are going
to interact with them?
General question, is you've
got a very rich, descriptive
account sort of focused on
particular words and themes,
and you have stories
associated with them.
To what extent did this
help you anticipate
what future censorship and
sort of dissident interactions
[INAUDIBLE]?
JASON Q. NG: Yeah,
I think what's
particularly interesting is
how internet users are trying
to shift away from this sort
of public face in social media.
So as a lot of folks in
authoritarian societies
have realized, that
posting material publicly
is great for
sharing information.
Sorry, I'll just
repeat the question.
So the question was about, how
does my research anticipate
what sort of future
shifts in trends
will take place in
social media in China.
So public facing social
media is a great opportunity
to connect with
folks, but it's also
an opportunity or a chance
for information controls
to be placed on it.
So I think a lot of
folks are shifting away
from public face in
social media, like Weibo,
towards more semi-public
or private social media,
like WeChat, and other
sorts of these chat clients
that a lot of folks are using
now on their mobile devices.
So in this way, you can still
have thousands of followers
on WeChat, and you can
blast out posts to them,
but there's
hopefully no overseer
sneaking in, and surveilling
your conversation,
and censoring you,
and potentially
dragging you to jail.
So I think that's
one potential shift.
AUDIENCE: Does your
research give you
any indication what
portion of the censoring
is somewhat automated,
and what portion is just
totally human-made?
JASON Q. NG: Yeah.
So the question was,
based on my research,
do I have a sense of how much
of the censorship is automated,
and how much of
it is human input?
I think looking at
my list, I think
it was fascinating-- especially
to me-- was most fascinating to
me was the human
element involved.
Like for instance, you'll notice
that the word Hoobastank was
blocked on Weibo for some
time, which was weird to me,
because from what
I know, Hoobastank
isn't a very politically active
band or music act in China.
But in fact, what I
think was happening
there was the
English word, tank,
which is part of Hoobastank,
was the blocked key word.
But in fact, when I
searched for the word tank
at that same time,
"tank" was unblocked,
and Hoobastank, or maybe the
word stank itself, was blocked.
So maybe there was
a typo somewhere.
So these are the sorts of
things that you uncover.
Other sorts of
research that I've
done at the Citizen Lab
with collaborators up there,
we've noticed also
various incidences
of human censor making mistakes.
Sometimes they'll uploaded a
list of blacklisted keywords,
and they'll
accidentally unencrypt--
or they'll accidentally
encrypt it the wrong way,
and it doesn't work,
and then you'll
see them frantically
uploading a new file,
like 30 minutes later.
So there's a human
element involved.
And I think providing
more insight
is this recent Reuters
story where they interview
actual censors-- human censors--
who work at these facilities.
This one was in Tianjin
outside Beijing.
And they said that there
was something close
several thousand censors
who work in a facility.
They work in shifts.
They work in 10-hour
shifts, and folks come in
and they-- but they do have
automated tools to help
them identify and flag
sensitive key words.
So there is computer
assistance involved.
There are algorithms
that they've written,
and they're constantly
getting better
in helping the human censors do
their job is more thoroughly.
AUDIENCE: So in the Workers
Revolution [INAUDIBLE],
one of the things
they did is they
did absurd things because it
would make the government feel
stupid to crack down on it.
They would meet in the square
[INAUDIBLE] that kind of thing.
You couldn't arrest people
for eating ice cream.
This workplace seems
absurd in the same way,
but Chinese government
seems to have
less of a worry about being
seen being silly or something.
I don't know.
Could you comment on
that difference in that
the use of absurdism
versus blocking what
seems like silly things.
JASON Q. NG: Yeah, like
I said with the question
before about how do
internet users walk
that fine line between
communicating to everyone,
and also still
evading the censors?
And one of the ways they
do it is with humor,
with funny images, which memes,
with sort of these inside
jokes.
So for instance,
back in recently
for the June 4th commemoration,
which takes place
every year in China,
internet users
actually posted an
image of the tank man,
but they were placed all the
tanks with this giant rubber
duck.
So you had four giant rubber
ducks facing off against a guy.
So that's absurd and silly,
and for the government
to crack down on that would
sort of be a statement about how
they're maybe not just
not in favor of discussion
of political sensitive content,
but also not in favor of humor.
So that's one method.
But yeah, it's
obviously a similar--
it's a topic that, I think,
internet users have recognized,
that you don't purposely--
you don't punch
the government in
the face perhaps.
They've learned that that's
not a very effective tactic.
We've seen from Liu
Xiaobo, other folks who
go out there directly
promoting political change.
They tend to get dragged
in, and that perhaps
isn't an effective tactic.
So what they do is they
organize things like everyone
wears a black t-shirt
on a particular day.
They go out and
walk the streets.
They take a stroll.
That's [SPEAKING CHINESE],
which is their method
for, I guess the sort of
eating ice cream in the square.
So I think both methods are
supremely important in terms
of fermenting change
in China and progress.
You need serious
political activists,
but you also need these sort
of light-hearted attempts
to sort of show how ludicrous
some of the censorship system
is.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] groups.
Is data available to do
your kind of analysis
on something like
that, like QQ groups
and QQ instant messaging,
that sort of stuff.
JASON Q. NG: Yeah,
QQ is another--
the question was about, can we
also track censorship on QQ,
which is a chat
client within China.
I checked, that's
used around the world,
but it's created by a Chinese
chat company called Tencent.
So yeah, it's
actually interesting.
One of the first real major
censorship gold mines--
or for censorship
researchers-- was actually,
I think it was late 1990s,
or-- I forget when it was.
But hackers actually
figured out that QQ
was storing on your computer
a certain file that basically
every time you typed
information in your chat window,
it would compare
it with this file.
And if anything was
contained in that file,
they would actually
censor your content.
So hackers actually
extracted the keyword list,
and actually shared that widely.
And I think that was one the
first instances of reverse
engineering the sort
of censorship that
is built into these
sort of systems.
So yeah, there's definitely
researchers who are actively
looking into various ways
that chat clients, like QQ
and WeChat and
other social media,
are actively censoring
and surveilling users.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
have on the effectiveness,
because it seems like
for all their censorship,
it may block some casual
users, but between all
the evasions and all the
way people rephrase things,
you said that basically--
the Red Cross incident,
they blocked a key
word, but it's still
affecting their
donations by 50%.
So does it seem like the
information is stilling
getting out to a
majority of people,
or is it only the ones who are
in the know, or [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON Q. NG: Yeah.
The question was
about how effective
do we actually think
these sort of blocking
and censorship is, because
based on what we've seen,
internet users are able
to evade the censors.
So I think the answer is that--
or I think one way to look at
is that we only know about
certain-- like for instance,
the Red Cross incident.
We know about that incident,
but what about the many dozens--
or for each of those
cases, many dozens of cases
that we don't know about?
So we may just have a
little tip of the iceberg.
We can see these sorts of
ways where internet users
were able to evade
the censors, and were
able to produce a
profound change.
But the whole point of
censorship is that it's obtuse.
We'll never find
out, we'll never
know unless more research
gets done, someone
releases this information,
that sort of thing.
So based on other
researcher people
have done, there's a study
by [? Yu ?] and Robinson
where they look into why people
actually want to evade censors
or why would people want to
escape restrictions in China.
And for the most
part, folks aren't
interested in engaging
in political activism.
Folks are really
pretty much interested
in just getting a stable
internet connection,
getting access to information.
And so based on
that sort of thing,
you get the sense that Chinese
internet users, the majority
of them are, for the
most part, satisfied
with the sort of material
that they have online.
They don't have
YouTube, but they Youku.
Instead of Facebook,
they have Yunyun.
So this sort of thing,
I think, appears
to be taking place in China.
But obviously, there
are hardcore, dedicated
folks who are focused on
expanding freedom of expression
in China, making
sure that there's
social justice, and
that sort of thing.
And they do play a large
role in the social sphere.
AUDIENCE: So your research seems
to be about the content that's
censored, but how
about the people.
Are they anonymous on
these social networks?
Are they tracked?
Are they surveilled?
Do they feel like they
may get in trouble
if post certain [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON Q. NG: Yeah.
Yeah, so the question was
about-- this is about content
that's being blocked, but
what about the people who
post this sort of content.
Do they fear for their lives?
Are there sort of ways for
the government to track them?
And the answer is yes.
Social media in China--
technically, for some time,
the government's imposed a
rule where social media had
to require that people their
real names to register.
So obviously, there are
loopholes to get around it.
So one of the ways that real
name registration required
was using your cell phone.
So sometimes, people would use
just throwaway cell phones,
and stuff like that.
But in theory,
technically every cell
phone that you sign
up for, technically
the vendor is supposed to have
your actual real information.
But that's China, or any
country where this sort of thing
is just like, come on, you're
really going to-- yeah.
So this has been a major issue,
especially with over the past
several months and
over the summer,
wherein Weibo and other social
media have been targeting these
so-called big V's-- these
verified users on Weibo who are
these celebrities.
They have millions of followers.
They are very powerful.
They're the power
users of Weibo.
And they're known publicly.
They're intellectuals, scholars,
activists, lawyers, but also
just like actors and
actresses, and stuff like that.
So we've seen
that-- and actually,
in March the Head of the State
Internet Information Office
actually brought in all of these
bunch of big V's, and actually
had dinner with them.
He called them in, sat
them down, and said,
look, we need to make sure
that social media in the future
isn't filled with rumors, isn't
filled with malicious lies.
We have to make sure
that what we're posting
is supportive of the
health of society.
So people got the message.
And over the summer actually,
there was a big crack down,
and a lot of these big V's
were actually dragged in.
There was one economic
writer, Charles Xue,
was actually brought in.
He had to do this
forced confession.
There are other folks who
have been arrested recently.
So it's clear that
the government
is very interested in
targeting individuals, as well,
in addition to
censoring content.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it seems that China
has its own version
of Twitter and things
that Youku for YouTube
and Baidu for Google.
How much urgency do you
sense from Chinese users
to use the Western generated
products versus use their own,
and have more
censorship on them.
Because I don't
sense a lot of need
to use Google over Baidu but it
obviously [INAUDIBLE] search.
JASON Q. NG: Yeah.
Obviously, there are
hardcore folks within China
who are very adamant about using
products that aren't censored.
So when Google did
pull out of China,
you had people laying wreaths
and flowers at the Google
Office, because they were
really saddened by the fact
that a company like
Google left China,
and now they were
forced to use products
like Baidu-- which if
you haven't used Baidu,
it's actually a pretty
good search tool
so long as you're not searching
for sensitive content.
So I think there are folks who
are very, very much into using
Twitter and YouTube
from within China.
And the thing is,
for the most part,
if you want to use Twitter
and Facebook within China,
you have the tools to allow
you to get access to them.
It's not like Iran
where sometimes they
throttle the
internet to the point
where you can't use YouTube.
You could actually
use-- well, now VPN's
a little more dicey
since it's harder to get.
It's a good, solid VPN
that works for a while.
But you can use various
types of circumvention tools
to get access to YouTube,
Facebook, Twitter
from within China
if you want to.
The thing is, most
folks-- why go
on Twitter when all your
friends are on Weibo?
It's network effect, so
it's fairly entrenched
at this point, Weibo and
other sorts of social media.
So I think for the most
part, Chinese internet users,
some of them may actually
use domestic products out
of patriotism.
For the most, I think folks are
just-- not necessarily lazy,
but that's the
thing that loads up
when they can start their
computer, that's what they use.
AUDIENCE: Just to follow
up about on the question
about people versus content.
The way for the content
creators side [INAUDIBLE],
is there any sense,
especially given
that it's not just
the China-- you
see global [INAUDIBLE]
metadata, data mining,
and query analysis post facto.
Is there any sense or
precedent that China
might be saving query
traffic across all users
to find who searched
for certain [INAUDIBLE]
browsing activity [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON Q. NG: Sure.
So the question was--
again, going back
to whether the government
is tracking people
with regards, especially
to sucking up metadata,
and whether or not
we think companies
like Sina or the government
are using this sort of metadata
as a way to figure out
who should be brought in
for questioning.
So I certainly
don't have knowledge
of metadata being used
in this sort of fashion.
I think from the sort
of anecdotal evidence
that we have, it's more
straight surveillance.
If they know that
your a activist,
they may get access to
your WeChat account,
and then start tracking
the messages you post.
And then when you
say, oh, I'm going
to be having lunch at
the Chaoyang Square
or whatever, they send an
officer who follows you.
And then you get
there, and you notice
how the officer is there, and
you wonder how they got there.
So that's the sort of thing
that I think their method
for tracking sensitive people.
As for figuring out-- from
the vast, big data who
might be terrorists
or whatever--
I'm sure that their
equivalent of the NSA
is doing the same sort of thing
that the NSA is doing here.
But I don't know if individual
netizens who are just,
like, looking at
pornography online
should be worried that
they're metadata's
going to be sucked up,
and then somehow they're
going to end up in prison.
I think the Chinese
authorities--
they're efficient.
They know who they
should be focused on,
and I think that's not
their primary target.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: A question just
referring to China's NSA,
and we haven't really
talked much about
who [INAUDIBLE] this censorship.
I wonder if they're
just concentrated solely
in the Propaganda Ministry
that has controls on this?
Or are there multiple
agencies or groups
that are involved censorship
in China, from what
you can infer from
your research?
JASON Q. NG: Yeah.
So the question was
about who's actually
performing the sort of
censorship, what government
agencies and/or
folks are involved.
And clearly, yeah,
it's something
that's politically
driven in some ways.
So you have this new bureau
called the State Internet
Information Office,
which is sort
of an offshoot of the State
Council Information Office,
which is now supposedly the
lead figure for performing
this sort of
information control.
But you have all
these other ministries
and bureaucracies
that are involved.
But you also have not just
these multiple agencies
and bureaucracies, but you
also to notice that there's
a national level of
information control,
but then you also have local
officials who are involved.
You have police,
security bureaus,
and other folks who have
different interests than maybe
the national agents.
So you have these
different layers.
And then you throw
into that, you
have private companies who have
a vested interest in preventing
any sort of potentially even
sensitive discussion taking
place on their site.
So you have another layer
of censorship there,
and then you have the
actual users themselves
who have to self-censor,
who actually report
on other users who are
posting provocative content.
So you have these
multiple layers,
and it's not very clear.
It's not as simple as they're
doing it, or it's them.
It's very much a de-centralized,
diffused censorship system,
which is, I think, a feature
of the Chinese system.
All right, I think
everyone is too scared,
and we're going
to call it quits.
All right, thanks so
much everyone for--
[APPLAUSE]